みなさんこんにちは
私は大学でデー経営学
その中で特にマーケティングを専門に教えている大学の先生です
経営学とは何かこれは経営者が企業をどういうふうに効率的にまたは
効果的に運用できるかということを学ぶ各者であります
しかし残念ながらケール学を学んだ学生さんがすべて起業家になるわけではありません
経営が不教えている先生としては経営学を学んだ学生さんが少なくてもその知識を自分
の家遠征の中でフル価値をしてもらいたい
その知識を利用して幸せになってもらいたいっていうものが実は本当の狙いではないか
なと思います
経営学の中で一番最初に考えなければならないこと
特に起業家が一番最初に考えなければならないこと
これ一緒
にしようとは何か
企業が衝撃的に達成しなければならないこと
最終的に到達できなければならない
霧氷のことであります
これは人々も人生にも見ています
人々はこのミッションがなければ幸せになれない
これをいつも私は中京で行っていることなんですね
天井になってから嬉しいことにいろんな覚醒さんと相談をしてするチャンスがあるわけ
なんです
特にその中では先生私は企業がしたいんです
会社を興して一生懸命に頑張りたいんですっていうもの生産があります
そういえば生産に私は質問しますあなたは起動してなればやりたいの
なぜなれば急なまあ各ミッションは何だ
で聞くと大体ございますそうですね
お金がいっぱい稼ぎたいですねております
お金をくれることはミッションではないあれは持って来ないではない
そういう目的で起業した絶対失敗します
お金を稼ぐというのはただの手段であります
その手段を達成し
カラーなる6ひょっとは一体何かというものを考えない限りはあなたは起業してはいけ
ないです
これをまた申請に持っているわけなんですね
だいたいこういう時って私は行きますじゃああなたの
牛名は何
夢ですね
そうですねなんでしょうかねっていう時にまた聴きますあなたな
一番を考えてください
あなたの鎮静の中で頭レットも
本館できない一番大事なもの
それを元にあなたは何も求めてみようと化す
それがあなたの八かでなるわけで
この勝ち
悪夢元にあなたは鎮静の目標を立てるわけですよ
じゃあ大飼ここまできましたあなたたちはあなたの地域も別居っていきたいなんだろう
大体の人は言います
そうですね幸せになりたいですね
幸せいいですね
でも幸せになれる思って
何でしょう幸せになれるを抵抗ってなんだと思うってを聞くとまた答えられない
面白いことに執行の幸せというものには変な魅力があります
世の中のすべてのものは知っ最古の賛否両論っていうものをご紹介します
すべてのものにはそれに賛同する人と反対する人を言うんですね
例えば結構
この中で既婚者の人と手を挙げてください
はいありがとうございます
ちょっと少ないんですけどね
結婚してない人々はこの公演が終わったハトコの人々に聞いてみてください
本当に結婚店にあるべきものなんですか
どういう答えが出てるかすごく気になるでしょう
私には効かないで下さいっ
もちろん私の結論まで結婚した方がいいかもしれないよということですけどね
んだよ
お金を一緒なんです
みんなお金があった方がいいんですよねお金もあればあるほどいいんですよねっていう
人もいれば
いや違うんですよお金って本当に生活苦のために最小限の量しか
量さえあればそれで十分ですよいい
いう人もあるわけなんですこういうふうに全てのことには反対する人と賛同する人が
できた
m 市青江だけ
みんな氏宛てになりたいと怪我
先生私を不幸になるために一生懸命に頑張っています
私の人生目標は不幸になることなんです
という人は誰もになるわけですね
みんな使用せになるというと願っている
でも幸せになる
方がわからない
だからこそ私はここで経営学で
出郷超しているひとつのテクにご紹介します
そのテクニックがパロップこれです
私は2
企業がミッションを設定し
その次にやらなければな
この星
たこと集中というものなんです企業がすべての市場相手にしてビジネスができるわけで
はない
広い市場の中で自分が一番適しているその市場に合わせてそれを選択してそれに向けて
ちゃんと集中してビジネスをやっていただければ成功できないというルールですね
その実際申請にも一緒なんです
あなたたち a 人団長か1日どれほどもセール価格で悩んでいると思います
ここの日になってネットを調べてみましたん
良い数字が出ました
麗人鞍上が1日で編宅で悩んでいるチャンスというものが
これぐらいの数字で表れます
信じられますかでも実際こういうふうに悩んでいるとネットが入っています
で私もまた調べてみましたこの政治
これは子どもだちが1日で悩んでいる選択の数かといっています
子どもたちがなぜ大人エイシアわけか分かりますよね
聖沢の風がはるかに少ない
でもこれはちゃんとした研究激化ではないので
ロン本をいろいろ調べてみました
そしたらこの政治が出ました2007年に発表されたこの論文からの数字は成人男女が
1日で食事だけでを悩んでいる
数
何を食べるかいつ食べるかどれほど食べるか
あった看護の食べるが覚めたものを食べるか
a 音がどれほどのものを食べるか
こんなくだらないこと道ティに8回も苦労して並んで考えているわけですね
それであなたは幸せになれますかあなたは幸せだと言えるんですか
今の人々は皆いています私は忙し
それがまるでしマンのようにいっていうわけなんです
再建をレイプおかしいんだよ最近私忙しいのそれが自分の
人生のステータ婦のように成功しているように見える
言えてるんですかそれって本当に幸せなんでしょうか
私はいつもいいソが死んだよって言ってる人って本当に幸せなんでしょうか
二世 new day
洗濯の障害という病気をみんな待っているわけなんです
正直私も持っていますこの選択の生涯という
特に時間に関しての選択の障害を持っている人を2種類に分けるとこんな感じになり
ます
暇な1位
また忙しい1位
シマノ島が人は元怠けた人間なんです
でも残念ながら忙しいとはただのバカなんです
自分が持っているようこの大事な時間っていうリソースをどういうふうに活用すれば
いいのかわからない
だからここで大事な戦略が正
選択と集中というものですあなたたちが鎮静の中で一番大事だと思っているその
選択をしたのであればそれに集中してまい進していくこと
私が教えている科目には勝者行動力という科目があります
この科目の中やまあこの科目で心理学から帰ってきたいろんなモデルがあるんですが
そのモデルの中でかなり私が日に入ってるも出ればこれです
た属性態度モデル
消費者が何がを買う時には直生
女性というものを考えて単位取っていうものを持つとそれがその製品が付か
または好きではないかっていう態度を保つためにはいろんな属性を判断して結果的に
態度を持つっていうモデルですね
これあげてみましょうバックです
私独居これはただのパックです
例えば私が彼女と一緒にデパートに行ったとしましょうねパックを選ぶチャンスがあり
ます
私はどういう直線を選ぶと思う
使うと思いますか
ただ価格なんです
私が見るも書くしかないんです安ければ買う
でも高ければ絶対買わないということです
でも彼女はどうでしょうもちろん価格も見ます
でモタード4番レッグ番目6番目くらいです
だいたい1番目真っ暗
サイズ金をして質ポケットの数
友達米
do you do ん
説明で10分20分くらい広いを比較して女性を比較して
下したペペロンがやっぱり買わない
今の女性を見よして悩んだあげて結果が一緒であればあなたは何でそんなに悩んでいる
7倍こそ女性悩まない方が洗濯を
客も少なくしたほうがもっと幸せになると思いませんか
私が教えているマーケティングではこういう戦略というものもあります
stpt にはなく
セグメンテーション企業があまりに虫場が広いのでその市場
セグメンテーションを細分化しキーターゲティング
一つのターゲットし墓域ポジショニング
自分の立ち位置を決めるっていう戦略なんです
先生そんな企業戦略なんか私の人生に役に立つわけない
じゃないですか
違う
中米手が小さい彼方のチンケな役に立つわけなんです
この例を見てみましょう
あなたにプラスに4人の女の子がいます
4人の子みんな変わる
正直インナー
彼女にしたいです私だって来ても何です
でも4人の女の子に一緒にアプローチしたからって4人を何個かはい祝いはあなたも
科学彼女になってあげるわよとは絶対言いません
さあここであなたは何をやるべきか
セグメンテーションただけ
ポジショニングなんです
この中でどれ誰が一番好みなのか
髪が短いのなんかご団子の粉のは髪が長い長い熊野化ファンドをしている子なのか
この中でターゲッティングしていくわけなんですさあ
まあ髪が長く変える
短い女の子に絞ろうでそれで自分の立ち位置をアピールしてポジショニングをしていく
わけなんですね
そうするとこの子の子は最初はすごくなれるだけど悩む必要だが
あの音楽に何て言えばいい
あの家にさ俺と一緒のあの赤い色の熱帯しているんだね
っていうことで話をかければたぶん彼女は自分に興味を示してくれば
くれるかもしれないこれが選択と集中ということですね
平成になってからいろいろな相談を受けることが多いと言ってましたがその中の一つは
出荷つってもので
先生
北
100枚ドライブ入力初回て100社くらいに履歴書を送ったんですけど
通りにもお願いしもらってないんですよてどうすればいいんですか
そりゃ当たり前でしょ
白にもに歴史を打ってその会社があなたのことを気に入ってくれると思うんですか
あなたは選択と集中ということをやっていない
自分の価値観に沿った自分のミッションを一緒に達成してくれる
海上ちゃんと選んでもなくてだったらむやみに履歴書を書いて魂のこもってない履歴書
を送って
あの会社があなたのことを気に入ってくれると思うんですか
これは恋愛と一緒なんですあなたのことをちゃんとアピールしなければ
no 会社もあなたのことを気に入って触れないんだから私のアドバイスは
多くても3社や王者に選んで
その会社のことをちゃんと理解してあなたがその会社のためになるができるかという
ことをちゃんとは pa しなさい
そしたら例ないと一緒に会社はあなたのことを愛してくれる
どう答えます
でもこんなすごい部と言っている割には私も同じ間違いをしたことがあります
これは妻私が働いている大学 apu で具材確定
私は2005年に日本の某大学で修士課程に行った時に
旬なきっかけで永久に来ることがありました
それでこのたぶん彼のこの環境でまたら
素晴らしい自然に折れてしまって絶対影響で働きたいと思いました
それで各党に会いに行きました
超僕まだ修士課程の学生なんですがいつかこの apu で大学の先生になりたいです
どうすればいいんですか
聞いたか調和やりました
この ap は2本しか理解してない各社はいらない
日本と海外の点火両方理解している学者だからこそ
やっとうって言ってました
私は選択をしました view しかないでまた集中をしました
すべてをつけて
アメリカに行きました
それで4年間一生懸命勉強していた
成分を撮りました
でも人生ってそんなものといいかなんですね私が葉加瀬部
取った時点ではイヨニは負けがありませんでした
でも食がなければ食っていけないので仕方なくこんなことをしていました
これはアメリカの地です私が当時風が店に行くときも私の研究室に貼ってあったし
いろんな大学に履歴書を送ってみました
1回計たとてもない以前名前も知ったこともない
そういう大学にただただ履歴書を送りました
その数この二戦の4
30大学に履歴書を送りました
もよく私2つの外角に超えました
よかったですね
あー専門の大学で働ければ働かなければ
でもその大学に関してを正直何も知らないこれからどうすればよくもって思った時に
apu に空きが出ました
これはチャンスだと思ってあの復活のタイガー蹴りました
それで apu に戻ってきました面接を受けました
課長さんやめていました
この校長さんにないんです私にアメリアのほかの大学から
形がをとって帰ってきたらやってくれるよという拡張はいなかったんです
でも幸いに当時の私同時の私を面接してくれたこの面接からたちは私の踏力を認めて
くれました
洗濯をして集中をしてその目標に向けて私の価値観追うごとにしたその目標に向けて
頑張ってくれた
私を認めてくれたから私は今この場に立って先生になってこういう講演会もできるよう
になって ok です
このパズを見てくださいもちろん覚えてますよね人々が1日でやっていく選択の数
あなたたちも多分朝起きてから数多くの選択をやってきたわけなんです
ラグーてと講演会ショットを申請したんだけど以降回来ないかいろいろ悩んだ結果この
場所に座っているわけなんです
あなたたちの選択は正しかったと言いたいんです
だからあなたたちはこの鉄塔 x apu というぱにー
そうやっているわけですね
この点灯 xx apu がーあなたたちの人生を変え
いいきっかけになってくれればと
切に願っています
あなたの価値観あなたがこれから
人生のすべてをこう記してもこれだけは
本目だけならも止めなければならないと思うその活動も考えている
その活動を持って夢を設定してください
その夢を達成
するための選択と集中を付け下さい
そうすればあなたたちは何
幸せになれると思います
ありがとうございました